شا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلا قد قامت الصلاه الله
اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
[Silence]
الله
استقيم
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب وقفينا من
بعده
بالرسل واتينا عيسى ابن مريم البينات
وايدناه بروح
القدس افكلما
جاء م
رسول بما لا تهوى انفسكم استكبرتم
ففريقا كذبتم
وفريقا
تقتلون وقالوا قلوبنا غلف بل لعنهم الله
بكفرهم فقليلا ما
يؤمنون ولما
جاءهم كتاب من عند الله مصدق لما معهم
وكانوا من قبل يستفتحون على الذين
كفروا فلما
جاءهم ما عرفوا كفروا به فلعنه الله على
الكافرين بئس ما اشتروا به انفسهم ان يك
فروا بما انزل الله بغيا ان ينزل الله من
فضله على من
يشاء من
عباده
فباءوا بغضب على غضب
وللكافرين عذاب
مهين واذا قيل لهم امنوا بما انزل الله
قالوا نؤمن بما انزل علينا ويكفرون بما
وراه ويكفرون بما
وراءه وهو الحق مصدقا لما
معهم قل فلم تقتلون
انبياء الله من قبل ان
كنتم
مؤمنين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين ولقد
جاءكم موسى بالبينات ثما اتخذتم العجل من
بعده وانتم
ظالمون واذ اخذنا ميثاقكم ورفعنا فوقكم
الطور خذوا ما
اتيناكم بقوه
واسمعوا قالوا سمعنا
وعصينا واشربوا في قلوبهم العجل
بكفرهم قل بئسما يامركم به ايمانكم ان
كنتم
مؤمنين قل ان كانت لكم الدار الاخ
عند الله خالصه من دون الناس
فتمنوا الموت ان كنتم
صادقين ولن يتمنوه ابدا بما قدمت ايديهم
والله عليم
بالظالمين
ولتجدنهم احرص الناس على حياه و من الذين
اشركوا يود احدهم لو يعمر الف
سنه وما هو بمزحزحه من العذاب ان
يعمر والله بصير بما
يعملون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله
ال
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
استقيموا
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
الله ولي الذين امنوا
يخرجهم من الظلمات الى
النور والذين كفروا
اولياؤهم الطاغوت
يخرجونهم من النور الى
الظلمات
اولئك اصحاب النار هم فيها
خالدون الم تر الى الذي
حاج ابراهيم في ربه ان اتاه الله
الملك اذ قال ابراهيم ربي الذي يحيي
ويميت قال انا احيي
واميت قال ابراهيم فان الله ياتي بالشمس
من المشرق فات بها من
المغرب فبهت الذي كفر والله لا يهدي القوم
الظالمين او كالذي مر على قريه وهي خاويه
على عروشها قال انا يحيي هذه الله بعد
موتها فاماته الله مئه عام ثم
بعثه قال كم
لبثت قال لبثت يوما او بعض
يوم قال بل لبثت مئه عام فانظر الى طعامك
وشرابك لم
يتسنه وانظر الى حمارك
ولنجعلك ايه
للناس وانظر الى العظام كيف ننشزها ثم
نكسوها
لحما فلما تبين له قال اعلم ان الله على
كل شيء
قدير واذ قال ابراهيم رب ارني كيف تحيي
الموتى قال اولم
تؤمن قال بلى ولكن
ليطمئن
قلبي قال فخذ اربعه من الطير فصرهن
اليك ثم اجعل على كل جبل منهن جزءا ثم
ادعهن ياتينك
سعيا
واعلم ان الله عزيز
حكيم مثل الذين
ينفقون اموالهم في سبيل الله كمثل حبه
انبتت سبع سنابل في كل
سنبله 100
حبه والله يضاعف لمن
يشاء الله واسع
عليم الذين
ينفقون اموالهم في سبيل الله ثم لا يتبعون
ما انفقوا منا ولا اذن لهم
اجرهم لهم اجرهم عند ربهم ولا خوف عليهم
ولا هم
يحزنون قول
معروف ومغفره خير من صدقه يتبعها
اذى والله غني
حليم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا
انفقوا من طيبات ما كسبتم ومما اخرجنا لكم
من
الارض ولا تيمموا الخبيث منه
تنفقون ولستم باخذيه الا ان تغمضوا
فيه واعلموا ان الله غني
حميد الشيطان يعدكم الفقر
ويامركم بالفحشاء
والله يعدكم مغفره منه
وفضلا والله واسع
عليم يؤتي الحكمه من
يشاء ومن
يؤتى الحكمه فقد اوتي خيرا
كثيرا وما يذكر الا اولو
الالباب وما
انفقتم من نفقه او نذرتم من نذر فان الله
يعلمه وما
للظالمين من
انصار ان تبدوا الصدقات فنع
ماه وان تخفوها وتؤتوها
الفقراء فهو خير لكم ويكفر
عنكم من
سيئاتكم والله بما تعملون
خبير الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
استقيم اعتدلوا
استو الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
تبارك الذي نزل الفرقان على عبده ليكون
للعالمين
نذيرا الذي له ملك السماوات والارض ولم
يتخذ
ولدا ولم يكن له شريك في الملك وخلق كل
شيء
فقدره
تقديرا اخذوا من دونه الهه لا يخلقون شيئا
وهم
يخلقون ولا يملكون
لانفسهم
ضرا ولا
نفعا ولا يملكون
موتا ولا
حياه ولا
نشورا وقال الذين كفروا انها
الا افك افتراه واعانه عليه قوم
اخرون فقد
جاءوا
ظلما
وزورا وقالوا اساطير الاولين اكتتبها فهي
تملى عليه بكره
واصيلا قل انزله الذي يعلم السر في
السماوات والارض انه كان غفورا
رحيما وقالوا ما لهذا الرسول ياكل الطعام
ويمشي في
الاسواق لولا انزل عليه ملك فيكون معه
نذيرا او يلقى اليه كنز او تكون له جنه
ياكل
منها وقال الظالمون ان تتبعون الا رجلا
مسحورا
انظر كيف ضربوا لك الامثال
فضلوا فضلوا فلا
يستطيعون
سبيلا تبارك الذي ان
شاء جعل لك خيرا من
ذلك جعل لك خيرا من ذلك
جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار ويجعل لك
قصورا بل كذبوا
بالساعه
واعتدنا لمن كذب الساعه
سعيرا
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بل كذبوا بالساعه واعتدنا لمن كذب
بالساعه
سعيرا اذا راتهم من مكان بعيد سمعوا لها
تغيظا
وزفيرا واذا القوا منها مكانا
ضيقا
مقرنين دعوا هنالك ث
لا تدعوا اليوم
ثبورا
واحدا وادعوا
كثيرا قل اذلك خير ام جنه الخلد التي وعد
المتقون قل اذلك خير ام جنه الخلد التي
وعد
المتقون كانت لهم جزاء
ومصيرا لهم فيها ما
يشاءون
خالدين كان على ربك وعدا
مسؤولا ويوم يحشرهم وما يعبدون من دون
الله
فيقول فيقول انتم اضللتم عبادي هؤلاء
ام هم ضلوا
السبيل قالوا سبحانك ما كان ينبغي لنا ان
نتخذ من دونك من
اولياء ولكن متعتهم
واباءهم حتى نسوا الذكر وكانوا قوما
بورا فقد كذبوا
بما تقولون فما
تستطيعون صرفا ولا
نصرا ومن يظلم منكم نذقه عذابا
كبيرا وما ارسلنا قبلك من المرسلين الا
انهم الا انهم لياكلون الطعام ويمشون في
اسواق واجعلنا بعضكم لبعض فتنه
اتصبرون وكان ربك
بصيرا الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورح ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
س
السلام
عليكم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته رب اشرح لي صدري ويسر لي امري
واحلل عقده من لساني يفقه
قولي
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
وبكه
‏andal title is the eloquence of divine
silence the eloquence of divine silence
so i wanted to present towards all of
you myar brothers and sisters my dears
and uncles
and beauful beautiful children i wanted
to present
examp parts in our
الله سبحانه
وتالى all
bey
think
ex beauty in the revelation and the
divine in is sim to
tr
‏however bey of silence isle and i toing
all our
that the first example is the first
ex
‏and compl that that
you in the name
of inf
‏ising
whether whatever the may
be and so this brings back towards all
of us that conscious of god that that
that cal point in
life
‏hi الرحمن
الرح الله سه
wal so that is first
exal does not explicit say in the name
of god i
blank it is you complete that it is you
it is your that comples
that the second one is a very
beautiful
ران ف
الع also not
aat e with e and so there is no speci in
that is and that e is سبحانه
وى
be
انما
العما
[Silence]
العر
‏think
سح
الله because itace and
because
follow e and there is no defle in front
of because e have after any الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سحان الله
الله
[Silence]
ement
‏ever and not least i respectful all
time and know
depending was
شكرت
لاي موسى عليه
السلام
را شكرت
لايد
الله سبحانه
وتالى حر موسى عليه
السلام شكرتم
يدكم لن شكرتم لازيدنكم
will
beed
[Silence]
الله
الله سبحانه
وتالى
يحان
الله
الله اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم
وسرس اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
[Silence]
الك
استقيم اعتدلوا
استووا الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وقال الذين لا يرجون
لقاءنا لولا انزل علينا
الملائكه او نرى
ربنا لقد استكبروا في انفسهم وعتوا عتوا
كبيرا يوم يرون
الملائكه لا بشرى يومئذ
للمجرمين ويقولون حجرا
محجورا وقدمنا الى ما عملوا من عمل
فجعلناه
هباء
منثورا اصحاب
الجنه يومئذ خير مستقرا واحسن
مقيلا ويوم تشقق
السماء بالغمام ونزل
الملائكه
تنزيلا
الملك يومئذ الحق
للرحمن وكان يوما على الكافرين
عسيرا ويوم يعض الظالم على يديه يقول يا
ليتني اتخذت مع الرسول
سبيلا يا ويل ليتني يا ويلله ليتني لم
اتخذ فلانا خ
لقد اضلني عن الذكر بعد اذ
جاءني وكان الشيطان
للانسان
خذولا وقال الرسول يا رب ان قومي اتخذوا
هذا القران
مهجورا وكذلك جعلنا لكل نبي
عدوا من
المجرمين وكفى بربك
هاديا
ونصيرا وقال الذين كفروا لولا نزل عليه
القران جمله
واحده كذلك لنثبت به فؤادك ورتلناه
ترتيلا
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين تبارك الذي جعل في
السماء
بروجا وجعل
فيها وجعل فيها سراجا
وقمرا
منيرا وهو الذي جعل الليل
والنهار خلفه لمن
اراد لمن اراد ان يذكر او اراد
شكورا وعباد الرحمن الذين يمشون على الارض
هونا واذا خاطبهم
الجاهلون قالوا
سلاما والذين يبيتون لربهم
سجدا
وقياما والذين يقولون ربنا اصرف عنا عذاب
جهنم ان عذا بها كان
غراما
انها
ساءت
مستقرا
ومقاما والذين اذا انفقوا لم يسرفوا ولم
يقتروا وكان بين ذلك
قواما والذين لا يدعون مع الله الها اخر
ولا
يقتلون ولا يقتلون النفس التي حرم الله
الا بالحق ولا
يزنون ومن يفعل ذلك يلقى
اثاما يضاعف له العذاب يوم القيامه ويخلد
فيه
مهانا الا من تاب وامن وعمل عملا صالحا
فاولئك
فاولئك يبدل الله
سيئاتهم
حسنات وكان الله غفورا
رحيما ومن تاب وعمل صالحا
فانه يتوب الى الله
متابا والذين لا يشهدون ال
واذا مروا باللغو مروا
كراما والذين اذا ذكروا بايات ربهم لم
يخروا عليها صما
وعميانا والذين يقولون ربنا هب لنا من
ازواجنا
وذرياتنا قره
اعين واجعل نا
للمتقين
اماما
اولئك يجزون الغرفه بما صبروا ويلقون فيها
تحيه
وسلاما خالدين فيها حسنت
مستقرا
ومقاما قل ما يعبا بكم ربي لولا
دعاء
م فقد كذبتم فسوف يكون
لزاما الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين ادنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليه غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
الرحمن علم
القران خلق
الانسان علمه
البيان الشمس والقمر
بحسبان
والنجم والشجر
يسجدان
والسماء رفعها ووضع
الميزان الا تطغوا في
الميزان واقيموا الوزن بالقسط ولا تخسروا
الميزان والارض وضعها
للانام فيها
فاكهه والنخل ذات
الاكمام والحب ذو العصف
والريحان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان خلق
الانسان من
صلصال كالفخار
وخلق
الجان من
مارج من
نار فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان رب المشرقين ورب
المغربين فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان مرج البحرين
يلتقيان بينهما برزخ لا
يبغيان فباي
بالاء ربكما
تكذبان يخرج منهما اللؤلؤ
والمرجان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان وله الجواري المنشات في البحر كال
الاعلى فباي
الاء
ربكما
تكذبان الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحم
يم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
كل من عليها
فان ويبقى وجه ربك ذو الجلال
والاكرام فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان يساله من في السماوات والارض كل
يوم هو في شان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان سنفرغ لكم ايها
الثقلان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان يا معشر الجن
والانس ان استطعتم ان
تنفذوا ان تنفذوا من اقطار السماوات
والارض
فانفذوا
لا تنفذون الا
بسلطان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان يرسل عليكما
شواظ من نار
ونحاس فلا
تنتصرون فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان فاذا انشقت
السماء فكانت
ورده
كالدهان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان فيومئذ لا يسال عن ذنبه ان
انس ولا
جان فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان يعرف المجرمون بسيماهم فيؤخذ
بالنواصي
والاقدام فباي
الاء ربكما
تكذبان هذه
جهنم هذه جهنم التي يكذب بها
المجرمون يطوفون بينها وبين حميم
ان فباي
الاء
ربكما
تكذبان الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
الله صلاه الشفع ان شاء
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والشمس
وضحاها والقمر اذا تلاها والنهار اذا
جلاها والليل اذا يغشاها
والسماء وما بن ها والارض وما
طحاها ونفس وما سواها فالهمها فجورها
وتقواها قد افلح من زكاها وقد خاب من
دساها كذبت ثمود بطغواها
اذ بعث
اشقاها فقال لهم رسول الله ناقه الله
وسقياها
فكذبوه فعقروها
فدمدم عليهم ربهم
بذنبهم
فسواها
فسواها ولا يخاف
عقباها الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
والعاديات ضبحا فالموريات
قدحا فالمغيرات
صبحا فاثرن به نقعا فوسطن به
جمعا
ان
انسان لربه
لكنود
وانه على ذلك
لشهيد
وانه لحب الخير
لشديد افلا يعلم اذا بعثر ما في
القبور وحصل ما في
الصدور ان ربه هم بهم يومئذ
لخبير الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه مل السماء والارض وملا ما شئت
من شيء بعد كما تحب وترضاه اللهم لك الحمد
انت قيوم السماوات والارض ومن فيهن ولك
الحمد انت قيم السماوات والارض ومن
فيهن ولك الحمد يا ربنا على كل حال اللهم
صل على سيدنا محمد في الاولين وصل على
سيدنا محمد في الاخرين وصل على سيدنا محمد
في كل وقت
وحين اللهم يا ربنا ويا مولانا ويا سميع
الدعاء يا ذا المن والعطاء يا ذا الجلال
والاكرام يا حي يا قيوم يا بديع السماوات
والارض ويا رحمن الدنيا والاخره
ورحيمهما اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا
في من عافيت وتولنا فيمن توليت وبارك لنا
فيما
اعطيت واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قدرت
وقضيت انك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى عليك انه
لا يذل من واليت ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت نستغفرك ربنا من جميع الذنوب
والخطايا ونتوب اليه
اللهم ارحمنا بالقران اللهم ارحمنا
بالقران اللهم ارحمنا بالقران واجعله لنا
هدى ونورا يا رب العالمين اللهم شفعنا
بالقران اللهم بلغنا فيه
النزل اللهم ارفع اللهم ارفع لنا اللهم
ارفع لنا المراتب يا رب العالمين بالقران
ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب النار ربنا تقبل منا انك انت
السميع العليم وتب علينا يا ربنا انك انت
التواب الرحيم اللهم تقبل صيامنا
وصلاتنا وقيامنا
ودعائنا وصالح اعمالنا على الوجه الذي
يرضيك عنا اللهم انا نسالك بكل اسم بكل
اسم هو لك اللهم انا نسالك باهلنا
المستضعفين من المسلمين خيرا في كل مكان
في غزه
والسودان وفي كل بقاع المسلمين وفي كل
مكان اللهم كن لهم معينا
ونصيرا اللهم ابن عليهم سور حمايتك اللهم
اجعل م في ضمانك اللهم ادخلهم في امانك
اللهم ادفع عنهم ودافع يا قوي يا عزيز
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما
يصفون وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
‏m
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله